this is it sausage Josh you're nice
it's a look at to not to look at to I
mean of course to look at I have to stop
talking stop talking I'm sorry you're
nervous I'm a little nervous
have a seat I'm just amazing you're even
on the app well you know it's almost
cuffing season so a girl's got to be in
the apps forging for winter yeah I guess
but you're alexandra daddario you're
beautiful you're successful how are you
even single I mean dating is hard Josh
doesn't matter who you are
let's just let's just relax we can have
a good time okay how about some music I
got a really cool jazz playlist I think
you'd like I love jazz with in fact if
you put jazz on I might have to slip
into something more comfortable
okay
I'll be right back hey hey did I ever
mention how I saw Baywatch 50 times in
the theater that's more like it
that's not what I was expecting yeah
well my panda ones in the wash so yeah
that's a perfect so what are you talking
about oh yeah dating Oh suck so much I
mean I'm just like I'm so sick of all
the head games yeah you know what I
poured some wine how about we toast it's
great oh but fair warning
a little wine so the government's from
my lizard people right and they're the
same people that are keeping Tupac in
the alien pyramids oh and Matthew
McConaughey is actually a robot made of
whiskey and plexiglass I have proof do
you want to see it here she was look you
brought that on our date the answers are
all here open your eyes ja okay I think
we should just call it a night maybe
this has been great but I know sorry I'm
so sorry what I'm so sorry I I told you
that mine makes me go a little crazy I I
didn't say anything naughty did I no not
naughty so much is really factually a
responsible can you forgive me please of
course
okay great c'est la vie oh my god you
speak French
okay well if you speak French though I'm
warning you like I might do things I'm
ashamed of wild things I'm a pebble
Josh
what were you talking about you know
what I think I think we should call
tonight that's it oh my god I'm scared
you away I was trying to be sexy and I
scared you away by being too wild I'm so
sorry
that's long I've been it actually I was
kind of turned on by you ripping the
apartment apart really yeah well then
what's the problem
I was thinking about it I can't be with
someone that thinks that the
government's run by lizard people I mean
everybody knows the government's run by
the Illuminati obviously the signs are
there Alexander everybody knows it when
diesel told me what it's all right here
don't you see I've been working on this
for months you are so ignorant you'll
know soon enough I really don't know
[Music]
you
[Laughter]